sedan j'ai appelé le feu lectrique et
que l'artiste a construit lui-même dans
son atelier de montparnasse à un rayon
d'action de 150 km et atteint la vitesse
de 75 kilomètres à l'heure
savez vous que peut-être donnant les
rues de paris seront privés nageant il
suffira qu elles soient balayés par des
caméras de télévision et à la préfecture
des fonctionnaires attentif
surveilleront sur de multiples écrans la
vie de la capitale tient à rollers
renvoyer deux motocyclistes à
l'intersection de la rue mazarine et de
la rue de seine c'est le moi je crois
que la mode du prophétique et le mode
annonce de futures le futur pour moi est
une catastrophe c'est le feu qui se
répandant sur notre surtout surtout les
gens quand les lettres les cheveux des
femmes en gros les régimes tombent avant
chaque révolution dans un pays les
femmes en tête qui font qu'elle est sur
le fameux je dise tout va bien
l'appareil en question
oui là c'est simple il consiste en un
boîtier le parc autocratique pour ainsi
des ouïes par lequel est un chargeur
c'est ça au fond vous avez reproduit une
carte à une certaine échelle te ment sur
un déroulement continu cc c'est exact
cette créature reprise au bond la balle
on devait disparaître entre les lames du
grand résonateur topologique curieux oui
car nous sommes sur hurriya où a été
assemblé pour la première fois un
transmetteur de matières qui permet de
voyager d'une étoile vers une autre
permet de franchir du goût d'années
lumière
vous pensiez la jeune femme que l'on
dérange à sa promesse qui répond
et qui a oublié de fermer les missions
images il vraiment aujourd'hui
le fond de l'air effraie marc bailly
fait chaud oui nous avons dit avoir
besoin d'une femme comme président des
états unis en 76 d'un noir président en
1981 en fait je pense que nous aurions
dû inverser ce serait probablement plus
facile d'avoir un président noir sommes
qu'un président blanc qui soit femme
parce que les préjugés contre la femme
sont probablement les plus profonds de
tous monsieur smith il est américain
dans le hard ça arrive quitte sa villa
au volant de sa voiture électrique
ils l'engagent sur un embranchement de
la route à guidage automatique qui le
conduit jusqu'à l' axe principal
là il coupe son moteur et il lit
tranquillement son journal le dessous de
sa voiture est entrée en contact avec
les contrôles électroniques attention
attendez que la gauche porsche jaguar en
2012 attendez que la gauche parle they
were mireille mathieu au goulag est
tricoté plus aéré du luxe plus besoin
d'acheter un journal on se branchera sur
les missions d'information sur
l'éditorial politique sur la chronique
de mode ou sur le compte rendu sportif
et la rue présentera un singulier
spectacle